hey guys so this video is mainly for
beginners or people that are new to
ketosis and this is entitled healthy
ketosis acceptable food list I put a
link down below of a document that you
can download and print out of all the
foods that are acceptable on a healthy
keto plan okay so that way you can have
everything on one document I'm just
going to summarize what's in this
document but when you print it out
you'll see the details all right so
you're going to see a list of types of
fats nuts and seeds different proteins
and realize when you eat food the fats
and protein are usually combined
together you're not going to see a pure
fat or pure protein okay
organ meats fish seafood veggies fruits
berries liquids vegan proteins and vegan
fats
so that'll be actually being this
document your carbs are gonna be between
20 grams to 50 grams per day not per
meal per day now as far as vegetables go
I'm not counting the vegetables in this
equation that's extra when you consume
vegetables people want to know is it
going to be raw is going to be cooked
I'm gonna recommend you do half and half
now when I recommend vegetables I
usually recommend 7 to 10 cups but I'm
not recommending 10 cups of Brussels
sprouts for example what I'm talking
about is if you were going to consume a
full 10 cups that would probably be of
like salad or leafy greens not even
necessarily spinach because that's high
in a chemical called oxalates but I'm
talking about leafy greens romaine
lettuce that type of thing but if you
have a salad let's say 6 cups or 5 cups
and then you have some cooked or steamed
or stir-fried cruciferous like brussel
sprouts or broccoli or asparagus those
types of vegetables then that would be
good because when you cook certain
vegetables you enhance the
bioavailability of certain nutrients ok
yet when you consume vegetables raw you
have other types of nutrients that are
higher because heat does destroy certain
nutrients so we're just gonna do 5050 I
like the combination of raw leafy greens
and then
steamed cruciferous or cooked
cruciferous vegetables that seems to
work now as far as fruits go that's
basically going to be limes or lemons
that's your fruit berries so I'm gonna
give you a list on what barriers you can
consume but of course you just have to
make sure we don't go over these this
range right here I'm going to talk about
the acceptable liquids and the
acceptable vegan proteins and fat that
you can consume but we really want to
make sure the quality is there and I'm
talking about like eggs for example you
want to pasture-raised
organic not necessarily just free-range
you know natural eggs we want
pasture-raised Organic where the
chickens are out there in the grass
consuming some of that food when we talk
about fish while caught when we talk
about meats we want grass-fed preferably
organic if you can get it as well now as
far as a quantity
we've talked about that right through
here and then bioavailability for
example if you're going to consume organ
meats you're going to get a much better
quality of active vitamin A and
bioavailable iron and other minerals and
even trace minerals compared to certain
vitamins like industrials like for
example the vitamin A and vegetables is
more like a pre vitamin A that has to be
converted but then again
vegetables are high in other nutrients
like folate and vitamin C for example so
I included in this list the healthy
foods and a ketogenic diet because
sometimes when you do a ketogenic diet
they might allow you to have low carb
ingredients that are actually not very
healthy okay so this list might be
slightly different than other lists that
you've seen when searching about keto so
click the link below download it print
it out and that way you'll have the
reference of exactly what you should eat
and what you should not eat
so if you want more knowledge on how to
create a healthy body subscribe now and
get daily notifications daily
notifications that sounds weird well
I'll just remind you on a daily basis
I've got that